salut romain monté près parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même journée
spéciale oui je sais qu'après des cas
oui enfin on a surtout deux événements a
prêté à la roma
un effort là aujourd'hui c'est un jour
spécial c'est l'anniversaire de dtc qui
a deux ans alors on a décidé de fêter ça
[Musique]
pour les deux ans de dtc j'ai une grande
nouvelle je sors un livre mon premier
livre et ça parle de quelqu'un dedans je
vous explique tout ce que vous devez
savoir sur votre caca d'un point de vue
scientifique et pratique mais je vous
parle aussi du caca à travers les âges
et à travers le monde du caca dans l'art
du caca dans la vie quotidienne du caca
du futur avec plein d'anecdotes et de
questions proposées par plein de
collègues youtube buzz et youtube heures
alors évidemment je vais pas tout vous
spoiler mais je vais quand même vous
apprendre cinq choses que vous ne saviez
pas
[Musique]
il ya une durée maximum à ne pas
dépasser
quand on est entrain de côté on connaît
tous des gens qui passent des heures sur
les toilettes et bah c'est une mauvaise
idée ni passé pas plus de 10 minutes au
delà ça veut dire soit que c'est pas le
moment auquel cas c'est pas la peine
d'insister soit que vous êtes constipé
là pour vous soigner soit que vous
n'êtes plus concentré sur votre
smartphone ou sur votre bouquin que sur
votre inventaire et ça ça peut couper
l'envié mais alors vraiment dans tous
les cas vous risquez au mieux des
fourmis dans les jambes
au pire des hémorroïdes et vous n'avez
pas envie d'en avoir fait ma confiance
et puis soyez sympa pensez aussi à celui
qui est en train d'attendre dehors c'est
chiant seule exception on peut rester un
peu plus longtemps
1 si on a une tourista ou la gastro par
exemple l'a oublié ce que j'ai à vous
dire
mais sauf le dernier point est donc cela
il vous concerne quand même penser au
suivant
nous remercions se retenir de faire caca
c'est une mauvaise passe est une
question qui revient assez souvent soit
parce qu'on a entendu notre mamie nous
le dira mais qu'on n'est pas trop sûr
que ce soit vrai soit parce qu'on est en
train de se chercher une excuse pour pas
aller déféquer dans des toilettes
publiques
et bah c'est vrai se retenir de crottet
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon parce que si
vous vous retenez par un mécanisme un
petit peu pointu le caca y remonte alors
un tout petit peu des romans de pas
jusqu'à mais il remonte et l'envi passe
comme on en a parlé au point précédent
alors vous allez me dire bakool l'envi
passe du coup le problème est réglé et
ben non parce que le cac a plus il reste
dans le côlon plus hyper de l'eau pluie
se dessèche et plus il est dur à sortir
du coup après on est constipé alors de
base est constipé
c'est pas agréable mais en plus quand on
pousse trop fort on risque encore de
choper des hémorroïdes
alors comme le dit poète trop fort y
aller faut y aller
les filles aussi concacaf alors je sais
je brise un tabou ancestrale mais je
suis formel les femmes font caca mais
est ce que vous savez à quoi ressemble
leur caca
[Musique]
pas du tout le caca féminin ressemble à
du caca parce que c'est du caca n'est
plus ni moins alors il ya quand même une
petite inégalités hommes femmes sur le
plan fécales les femmes font a priori
moins souvent kaka que les hommes et ça
pour deux raisons a priori la première
allée hormonal les hormones féminines
ralentirait le mouvement des intestins
et la seconde elle est culturelle
quand on a une princesse on crée pas
kaka se fait pas les femmes se
retiendrait plus en public donc serait
plus facilement constipé vous avez
compris là on a une espèce de vieux
restes de trucs moyenâgeux qui laisse
encore des traces aujourd'hui espèce de
vieux patriarcat cas bon après ça reste
une moyenne 1
personnellement je connais des filles
qui laissent pas leur part aux chiens et
grand bien leur fasse
vous ne faites pas kaka dans la bonne
position
il ya toujours des cas particuliers bien
sûr mais je pense pas beaucoup nous
tromper si je dis que globalement vous
déféquer à 6 c'est une erreur
en tout cas c'est pas la meilleure
position en effet pour crottés accroupi
parce que c'est dans cette position que
votre rectum et votre anus sont
parfaitement alignés comme les planètes
dans les horoscopes alors c'est pas la
peine d'aller vous achetez une litière
ou de faire des acrobaties un peu
dangereux sur votre lunette des chiottes
vous glissez juste un petit support sous
vos pieds histoire d'avoir les genoux
plus haut que les hanches et là c'est
bon c'est nickel on dit merci qui
le cac a fait de l'art alors bon ok je
suis enfant un peu le truc on sort par
van gogh à chaque fois qu'on entre
l'être mais le caca à inspirer
énormément d'artistes d'une manière ou
d'une autre des peintres comme picasso
ou toulouse-lautrec des musiciens plein
de musiciens
[Musique]
des sculpteurs etc
et je vous parle même pas du cinéma
lassé il ya même des musées du caca dans
plusieurs pays ah qu'est-ce que tu
savais tout ça peut-être bien sûr un
écoute puisque tu es si malin et vu
qu'il nous reste pas beaucoup de temps
je vais te faire un petit quiz on peut
venir du caca vrai corps rec
bon c'était facile parce qu'on en avait
déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur les pires
matière du corps humain donc oui on peut
vomir du caca
mais c'est pas bon signe on peut uriner
du cac à faux mais non c'est vrai on
peut uriner du caca mais c'est pas bon
si on peut faire des greffes de kaka
faut il peut faire des greffes de kaka
en réalité c'est plus la flore
intestinale qu'on greffe à partir de
kaka mais c'est un traitement très
prometteur pour plein de maladies
on peut faire cuire ses pattes avec son
caca alors là faut faut faire du gaz à
partir de son caca et du coup faire
cuire ses pattes avec bien même des
entreprises qui vendent le dispositif
pour faire ça soit même et il ya des
tutoz sur internet pour fabriquer le
matériel soi même mais bon je le
conseille pas forcément on peut manger
son caca vrai c'est très peu conseiller
on peut déféquer en couple au fossat
finalement on peut déféquer en couple à
rebonds pas forcément en même temps dans
la même pièce mais même après votre
première nuit ensemble
vous pouvez aller crottés alors c'est un
petit peu loin mais il ya mille astuces
dans mon bouquin et vous trouverez
forcément celle qui vous convient
d'ailleurs tous les autres points dont
on vient de parler sont aussi détailler
précisément dans mon bouquin et plein
d'autres aussi parce que je réponds à
toutes les questions que vous vous
posiez sur le caca et même à plein que
vous vous posiez pas avec des anecdotes
des fan fan des conseils pratiques etc
je vous invite donc chaleureusement à
vous procurer le plus rapidement
possible cet ouvrage qui fera date dans
l'histoire fécales chez votre libraire
si vous en possédez un ou si vous n'en
possédez pas n'importe où vous avez
l'habitude de vous procurer le bouquin
il y en a partout
il s'appelle tout ce que vous devez
savoir sur le plus tabou des sujets et
il sort aux éditions michel lafon le 19
avril
c'est à dire demain si vous regardez
cette vidéo le jour où elle est sortie
ou hier si vous regardez cette vidéo
le vent auquel cas base abonnés vous
mettez la cloche tout ça comme ça la
prochaine fois vous serez pas en retard
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin de votre
transit
mettez vous bien et surtout des faits
portez vous bien